From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. So back in 2012, we ran this completely outrageous story about some stuff that the FBI did about an undercover informant who spied on American Muslims for over a year. And it went badly, like spectacularly badly. And some of those people who were spied on, some of the people in the story, sued the US government because of it. It's taken years to wind through the courts. But just last month, it was argued before the US Supreme Court.
这里是芝加哥WBEZ电台的《美国生活》，我是艾拉·格拉斯（Ira Glass）。回到2012年，我们播出过一个极其离谱的故事，内容关于联邦调查局（FBI）的一名卧底线人曾监视美国穆斯林长达一年多。结果非常糟糕，可以说是灾难性的糟糕。故事中一些被监视的人因此起诉了美国政府。案件经过多年法院审理，上个月刚刚在美国最高法院进行了辩论。
So today, I want to play you the story and also talk about the court case a little. Some context for the story before we start, it's about FBI surveillance of Muslims. Ever since 9/11, there's been a ton of that. And just to give a sense of what that means, our original episode opened in Queens, New York City one Saturday night at a community center. Three dozen people show up. Their kids run around before it starts, coffee in the back. It's a workshop run by two lawyers, Ramzi Kassem and Diala Shamas, who were with a project called CLEAR from the City University of New York Law School that gives free legal aid to Muslims who get caught up in counterterrorism surveillance investigations.
所以今天，我想把这个故事播给你们听，同时也谈谈这个诉讼案。在我们开始之前，先交代一下故事背景：这是一个关于FBI监视穆斯林的故事。自“9·11”事件以来，这类监视行动非常频繁。为了让大家了解具体情况，我们最初的节目是从纽约皇后区一个周六晚上的社区中心开始的。大约三十多人参加，活动开始前，孩子们在跑来跑去，后面放着咖啡。这是一个由两位律师——拉姆齐·卡塞姆（Ramzi Kassem）和迪亚拉·沙马斯（Diala Shamas）主持的研讨会。他们来自纽约市立大学法学院的一个名为CLEAR的项目，专门为那些卷入反恐调查的穆斯林提供免费法律援助。
So what we want to do today is nothing controversial. We just want to arm you with the knowledge of your rights so that you know how to respond when you find yourself, if you find yourself [SPEAKING ARABIC], in that really uncomfortable situation where you have an FBI agent at your door or an NYPD detective at your workplace, asking to talk to you.
我们今天要做的事一点也不敏感。我们只是想让你了解自己的权利，这样当你发现自己——如果你发现自己[讲阿拉伯语]——处于那种非常尴尬的情况，比如FBI特工敲你的门，或者纽约警察局的侦探来到你的工作场所要求和你谈话时，你知道该如何应对。
This is so common. It happens so often. Kassem and Shamas told me that sometimes they ask for a show of hands at these workshops, and they learn that every single person in the room has either been visited by law enforcement like this or know somebody who has. The two attorneys start with a demonstration of what happens in one of those encounters. Diala Shamas plays the plainclothes FBI agent who comes to the door. Ramzi Kassem plays the guy at home.
这种情况太普遍了，发生得太频繁了。卡塞姆和沙马斯告诉我，他们有时会在研讨会上请大家举手，结果发现屋子里的每个人要么曾经历过这种执法人员的盘问，要么认识有过类似经历的人。这两位律师先演示了一次这样的互动场景。迪亚拉·沙马斯扮演那名上门敲门的便衣FBI特工，拉姆齐·卡塞姆扮演屋主。
We're first going to do it the wrong way. This is how this interaction should not happen.
我们先演示错误的做法。这是互动绝对不应该发生的样子。
Knock, knock.
咚，咚。
Yes, hello?
你好，有人吗？
Hi.
你好。
Is this Ramzi Kassem's house?
这是拉姆齐·卡塞姆的家吗？
Yeah, this is me.
是的，是我。
Great. Can I just come in?
太好了。我能进去吗？
Sure, of course. Yeah, come in, please.
当然，请进。
Thanks.
谢谢。
Yeah. Who are you? I'm sorry, I didn't--
好的。你是谁？抱歉，我没……
Oh, my name is Diala. I'm with the FBI. I'm just here to ask you a couple of questions.
哦，我叫迪亚拉。我是FBI的。我只是来问你几个问题。
Oh, wow, FBI. OK, sure.
哦，哇，FBI。好的，没问题。
Nothing to worry about. Just a standard, we're getting to know the neighborhood. I'm new here, so--
不用担心。只是例行公事，我们正在了解周边社区的情况。我刚搬过来，所以……
Later, in the discussion afterwards, the audience points out that this was a mistake. He should have asked her ID before letting the FBI agent into his home. And he doesn't have to answer any questions. He could have even asked for a warrant. The crowd also points out that he seems very nervous-- another mistake.
随后在讨论环节中，观众指出这是一个错误。在让FBI特工进屋之前，他本应该要求对方出示证件。而且他完全没有义务回答任何问题。他甚至可以要求对方出示搜查令。观众还指出他看起来非常紧张——这也是一个错误。
So do you go to the mosque down the street?
那么，你会去街角的那家清真寺吗？
Yes, Dardal?
是的，Dardal？
Dardal, yeah, yeah. OK, and who's the imam there?
对，Dardal，没错。好的，那里的阿訇是谁？
Wait, why are you--
等等，你为什么要……
Oh, I'm just curious. It's part of my-- I just want to make sure that I say the right thing when I meet the right people.
哦，我只是好奇。这是我的工作……我只是想确保我在见到合适的人时，能说正确的话。
Oh, OK. Yeah, no, he's been the imam there for a number of years. And he's from Egypt. I can't remember his name.
哦，好的。他是那里的阿訇，已经很多年了。他是埃及人。我不记得他的名字了。
OK. You can't remember his name?
好的。你不记得他的名字？
Yeah, yeah.
是的，是的。
Oh, OK. So is it Mr. Abu Jamil?
哦，好吧。那是阿布·贾米尔（Abu Jamil）先生吗？
No, I don't think that's him. He's one of the leaders. He's one of the organizers there.
不，我不觉得是他。他是那里的领袖之一。他是那里的组织者之一。
The agent asks who else lives in the house. She asks, what does he think about the political situation in Egypt?
特工问还有谁住在这个房子里。她问他对埃及政治局势有什么看法。
Do you have an ID?
你有身份证件吗？
Yeah. Yeah, sure. Sure, here's my ID.
有的。好的，没问题。给你我的证件。
They talk a little more about politics. The agent thanks him for his cooperation, says she may come back with more questions.
他们又谈了一些关于政治的话题。特工感谢他的配合，说她可能会带着更多问题回来。
OK.
好的。
Thank you.
谢谢。
Thank you. Thank you.
谢谢你。谢谢。
Have a good day.
祝你有愉快的一天。
You, too.
你也是。
So--
那么……
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
You should not be applauding that performance.
你们不应该为那场表演鼓掌。
What went wrong in this?
这里面出了什么问题？
[INAUDIBLE]
[听不清]
So the brother is pointing out that there was a lot of volunteering of information.
这位兄弟指出，刚才透露了太多信息。
So it's difficult, right? Because I was being sort of friendly. And why wouldn't you volunteer that information if you don't think that you've done anything wrong?
这很难，对吧？因为我表现得很友好。如果你认为自己没有做错任何事，为什么不主动提供信息呢？
And the problem with that, the two lawyers tell the crowd, is that the more you say, the more you could accidentally be incriminating yourself, especially dangerous, they say, with those moments in the demonstration where Kassem was nervously stumbling around, not sure what to say, trying to remember.
两位律师告诉观众，问题的关键在于：你说得越多，就越可能在无意中让自己陷入困境。尤其是在演示中，当卡塞姆紧张得结结巴巴、试图回忆细节时，这种做法非常危险。
Under federal law in the United States, lying to a federal agent is a federal offense. It's a crime. And it's a crime that's being charged since 9/11 disproportionately against Muslims. So the moment that you have that interaction with the federal agent-- let's say I didn't remember something. And Diala asks me a question-- oh, you're friends with Cyrus. Where were you last Tuesday? And I say, oh, I think we were camping. But maybe she spoke to Cyrus before, and Cyrus said something different. So all of a sudden, there's a discrepancy. Either I'm in trouble, or Cyrus is in trouble. And so even having that very basic conversation--
根据美国联邦法律，对联邦探员撒谎是联邦罪行。自“9·11”以来，这项罪名在针对穆斯林的起诉中被不成比例地使用。所以当你与联邦探员互动时，假设我记错了某事。迪亚拉问我一个问题——哦，你是赛勒斯（Cyrus）的朋友。上周二你在哪？我说，哦，我想我们去露营了。但也许她之前已经问过赛勒斯，赛勒斯说了不同的版本。突然间，出现了出入。要么是我有麻烦了，要么是赛勒斯有麻烦了。所以，即使只是进行那种基础的对话……
Because of this, he tells the group-- over and over he says this-- if the FBI or NYPD comes around asking these general questions, it is best to get a lawyer.
正因如此，他反复告诉大家：如果FBI或纽约警察局来问这类笼统的问题，最好还是找律师。
We're not saying never talk to them. That's not what we're saying. What we're saying is, do it in a way that is responsible. And it's nothing controversial. It's what Martha Stewart does when she was approached by the FBI. She didn't talk to them directly. She retained lawyers. When President Clinton was under investigation, he had a team of lawyers.
我们并不是说绝对不要和他们说话。我们不是这个意思。我们的意思是，要以负责任的方式去做。这并不敏感。玛莎·斯图尔特（Martha Stewart）当年被FBI询问时就是这么做的。她没有直接与他们交谈。她聘请了律师。当克林顿总统接受调查时，他也有一个律师团队。
So that's the safe, responsible way to do it. And it's not being uncooperative. It's actually the most American thing to do.
这就是安全、负责任的做法。这并不是不配合。事实上，这是最地道的美国做法。
This particular workshop happened in 2012, but CLEAR and other organizations still give workshops like it today. I called around to a bunch of lawyers from different groups, and I don't know, I had assumed that 20 years since 9/11, the surveillance of Muslim communities would have slowed some. But everybody told me the same thing. It's the same today or greater than it's been in the past.
这个研讨会是在2012年举办的，但CLEAR和其他组织今天仍在举办类似的研讨会。我联系了不同团体的许多律师，我本以为“9·11”过去20年了，针对穆斯林社区的监视应该有所缓解。但每个人都告诉我同样的话：今天的情况和过去一样，甚至更严重。
The Council on American-Islamic Relations' Office in Southern California has more cases of law enforcement knocking on people's doors, plus, in addition to that, a real explosion in Muslim travelers being questioned at the airport. When I reached Ramzi Kassem this week on the phone, the lawyer from that workshop in 2012, he also pointed out that airports are a big deal these days.
美国-伊斯兰关系委员会（CAIR）南加州办公室处理的执法人员上门案例更多了，此外，在机场被盘问的穆斯林旅客数量也出现了爆炸式增长。这周我电话联系到了拉姆齐·卡塞姆，也就是2012年那场研讨会的律师，他也指出机场是现在的一个大问题。
We're seeing surveillance at airports, where people traveling back from overseas from Muslim-majority countries are having their electronic devices confiscated and all of the data dumped, or they're being questioned at airports and secondary screening.
我们看到在机场出现了监视行为，那些从穆斯林为主的国家旅行回来的人，他们的电子设备被没收，所有数据被拷贝，或者他们在机场接受二次安检时受到盘问。
Is it legal to take somebody's phone, if they're an American citizen and they're crossing into the country, and take the data?
作为一名美国公民，在入境时被扣押手机并提取数据，这合法吗？
That's a really good question. It's a contested question. We fought in court. The government takes the position that the Fourth Amendment does not apply at the border and that an airport is a border. And so they claim that your phone-- this is the US government's position across administrations-- is that your phone is just like a suitcase that they can search, and that if you're crossing an international border with it, they have the right to that data. They can take it. They can save it to their databases. They can share it with partners. So that's their position.
这是一个非常好的问题。这是一个有争议的问题。我们曾在法庭上据理力争。政府的立场是第四修正案不适用于边境，而机场就是边境。所以他们声称你的手机——这是美国政府历届政府的一贯立场——就像一个他们可以搜查的行李箱。如果你带着它越过国际边境，他们就有权获取这些数据。他们可以拿走它，可以存入他们的数据库，可以与合作伙伴共享。这就是他们的立场。
Basically, what happened was in the years after 9/11, the FBI built an infrastructure to do surveillance and look for terrorist plots, and now that it's in place, it just chugs along. Under our Constitution, the First Amendment's freedom of religion, it would be illegal for the government to go target somebody for surveillance just because they practice a particular religion. They can't go and knock on their door to ask you a few questions. They can't stop them at the airport. They can't investigate simply because they're Muslim.
基本上，“9·11”之后的几年里，FBI建立了一套监视和寻找恐怖阴谋的基础设施。现在它已经到位了，就一直在运转。根据宪法第一修正案的宗教自由条款，政府仅仅因为某人信奉特定宗教而将他们作为监视目标是违法的。他们不能随便去敲门问几个问题，不能在机场拦截他们，不能仅仅因为他们是穆斯林就调查他们。
And the case that you're about to hear-- the case that was argued at the Supreme Court last month; it's called FBI versus Fazaga-- at its heart is about that. It's a landmark case about whether the government's actions gathering information on Muslim citizens since 9-11 have been constitutional. The tactics used by the FBI in this particular case are tactics that they often use when they surveil Muslim communities, like using informants. The last time the FBI publicly stated how many informants it had, the number was 15,000.
你即将听到的这个案件——上个月在美国最高法院辩论的案件，名为《联邦调查局诉法扎加案》（FBI v. Fazaga）——其核心就在于此。这是一个里程碑式的案件，关乎政府自“9·11”以来搜集穆斯林公民信息的行为是否符合宪法。在本案中，FBI使用的策略正是他们监视穆斯林社区时经常使用的策略，比如使用线人。上次FBI公开承认他们拥有线人的数量时，数字是15000人。
But in a bunch of ways, this case is not typical. It's an outlier, a case where we can watch everything go wrong. Not just from the point of view of the people being surveilled-- the informant isn't happy how it worked out, and we presume the FBI cannot be too pleased either for reasons that you'll hear. Beyond all that, like I said, it's a compelling and very weird case. Stay with us.
但在许多方面，这个案子并不典型。它是一个异数，一个我们可以全程围观事情如何搞砸的案例。不仅是从被监视者的角度来看——线人对结果不满意，而且我们可以推测，由于接下来你将听到的原因，FBI对此也不会太高兴。除了这一切，正如我所说，这是一个引人入胜且非常离奇的案件。请继续收听。
Act 1, Gym Rat. So this happened in Orange County, California in 2006. And at that point, at least one homegrown terrorist had come out of an Orange County mosque and gone to work with Osama bin Laden, was on the FBI'S most wanted terrorist list, and relations between the FBI and Muslims in Orange County, California were already on edge before this story began-- so on edge that the head of the FBI for Los Angeles, Stephen Tidwell, decided that he should do a town meeting at a mosque in Orange County-- it was the Islamic Center of Irvine-- where he said emphatically that the FBI was not monitoring Muslim student groups in the area or the mosque itself.
第一幕，健身房常客。这件事发生在2006年的加州奥兰治县。当时，至少有一名本土恐怖分子出自奥兰治县的一座清真寺，后来去为本·拉登工作，登上了FBI的恐怖分子通缉名单。在这个故事开始之前，FBI与奥兰治县穆斯林之间的关系就已经非常紧张了。紧张到什么程度呢？洛杉矶FBI负责人史蒂芬·蒂德威尔（Stephen Tidwell）决定在奥兰治县的一座清真寺举行城镇会议——那是尔湾伊斯兰中心——他在会上坚决表示，FBI并没有在监视该地区的穆斯林学生团体或清真寺本身。
The crowd did not buy this. Somebody in the audience told Tidwell that it would be naive for them to believe that the FBI was not monitoring the mosque. Everyone should understand that they were being monitored, he said. Tidwell interrupted.
听众并不买账。台下有人告诉蒂德威尔，如果他们相信FBI没有监视清真寺，那未免太天真了。他说，每个人都应该明白他们正处于被监视中。蒂德威尔打断了他。
Look, one, no, you're not.
听着，第一，不，你们没有。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
If we're going to come to mosque, to come to service, we will tell you we're coming to church.
如果我们去清真寺，去参加仪式，我们会告诉你们我们要去教堂。
You will send your agents without anybody knowing.
你们会在不让任何人知道的情况下派遣探员。
The man in the audience replied, "You will send your agents without anybody knowing."
台下的那个人回答说：“你们会在不让任何人知道的情况下派遣探员。”
Well, what I'm saying, FBI, we will tell you we're coming for the very reason we don't want you to think you're being monitored.
我刚才的意思是，FBI，我们会告诉你我们要来，正是因为我们不想让你们以为自己被监视了。
That was June 5, 2006. As best as we can determine from people at the mosque and from testimony in court, two months after Tidwell reassured them that the FBI would not monitor them without telling them, the FBI placed an undercover informant in the mosque. And this is where our story begins. Sam Black is our reporter.
那是2006年6月5日。根据我们从清真寺民众和法庭证词中确定的信息，就在蒂德威尔向他们保证FBI不会在不告知的情况下监视他们两个月后，FBI就在清真寺安插了一名卧底线人。我们的故事就从这里开始。萨姆·布莱克（Sam Black）是我们的记者。
The informant in this story is named Craig Monteilh, and like a lot of people who go undercover to catch criminals, he used to be a criminal himself. He's done time for forging checks, embezzlement, and grand theft. At one point, he made a living stealing cocaine from drug dealers.
这个故事中的线人名叫克雷格·蒙泰伊（Craig Monteilh），像许多为了抓捕罪犯而卧底的人一样，他自己曾经也是个罪犯。他曾因伪造支票、挪用公款和重大盗窃罪入狱。有段时间，他靠从毒贩手中窃取可卡因谋生。
As I reported this story, people who know him described him as a snake, a chameleon, a thug scam artist, and, quote, a piece of [BLEEP]. And Craig says some pretty far-fetched things, like this list of aliases. He told me he used all of these in undercover stings.
我在报道这个故事时，认识他的人将他描述为一条蛇、变色龙、暴徒、骗子，用那个词来说，就是个“烂人”。克雷格说了一些相当离谱的事情，比如他那个别名清单。他告诉我他在卧底行动中使用了所有这些身份。
Italian drug dealer Vincent Donado, a Russian hit man by the name of Ivan Chernyenko. Colombian drug dealer Pedro Hernandez. A Bulgarian drug dealer by the name of Sergei Gerd. Also, I went by Polish names. One was Lech Vlesky.
意大利毒贩文森特·多纳多（Vincent Donado），名叫伊万·切尔年科（Ivan Chernyenko）的俄罗斯杀手。哥伦比亚毒贩佩德罗·埃尔南德斯（Pedro Hernandez）。名叫谢尔盖·格德（Sergei Gerd）的保加利亚毒贩。还有，我还用过波兰名字。其中一个是莱赫·弗莱斯基（Lech Vlesky）。
It's unclear if any of these are real, but some of the unlikely things Craig says do check out, like the fact that he worked on a counter-terrorism operation for the FBI. The Bureau has confirmed this. In 2006, the FBI enlisted him to go undercover to catch people who were recruiting and training terrorists. Craig says it all began at a strip mall Starbucks where he met with two FBI agents, Paul Allen and Kevin Armstrong. He says they told him they wanted him to go undercover. They'd pay him to infiltrate the Muslim community in Orange County-- which is a funny thought, because Craig's not the most inconspicuous guy.
目前还不清楚这些名字中是否有真实的，但克雷格说的一些不太可能的事情确实属实，比如他确实为FBI执行过反恐行动。FBI已经确认了这一点。2006年，FBI招募他卧底去抓捕那些招募和培训恐怖分子的人。克雷格说这一切开始于一家商场的星巴克，他在那里见了两位FBI特工，保罗·艾伦（Paul Allen）和凯文·阿姆斯特朗（Kevin Armstrong）。他说他们告诉他，他们想让他去卧底。他们会付钱给他，让他打入奥兰治县的穆斯林社区——这想法挺逗的，因为克雷格不是那种不引人注目的人。
I'm 6'2", 260 pounds. It's not fat. It's lean body mass. I bench 500 pounds. I have 21 and 1/2-inch arms.
我身高6英尺2英寸（约1.88米），体重260磅（约118公斤）。不是胖，是精壮的肌肉。我卧推能推500磅。我的手臂有21.5英寸粗。
But according to Craig, the FBI wanted to use his lean body mass to their advantage.
但据克雷格说，FBI想利用他这种精壮的体格优势。
I was to lure Muslim males into the gym using my physique to see what actually is the real pulse of the Muslim community. They told me what I did was vital to America's national security and to do exactly what they said.
我的任务是利用我的身材，诱导穆斯林男性去健身房，看看穆斯林社区真正的脉搏是什么。他们告诉我，我所做的事对于美国的国家安全至关重要，让我完全按照他们说的做。
And did they have particular targets in the Muslim community in mind?
他们对穆斯林社区里的特定目标有想法吗？
No. They said the targets would come to me.
没有。他们说目标会自己找上我。
The FBI wouldn't talk to me for this story because the operation is still classified, and because it's the subject of a lawsuit. But the FBI later confirmed in court that Craig was an undercover informant. A district attorney also stated in court that Craig did work with agent Kevin Armstrong, and that Craig had given the FBI, quote, "very, very valuable information." The FBI also confirmed one other thing-- the name of Craig's operation.
由于该行动仍处于保密状态，且是一起诉讼的主题，FBI没有接受我的采访。但FBI后来在法庭上证实了克雷格确实是一名卧底线人。一位地方检察官也在法庭上表示，克雷格确实与探员凯文·阿姆斯特朗合作过，并且克雷格向FBI提供了“非常有价值的信息”。FBI还确认了另一件事——克雷格行动的代号。
Operation Flex-- F-L-E-X.
“Flex行动”——F-L-E-X。
One Thursday in August, 2006, Craig showed up at the Islamic Center of Irvine-- one of the biggest mosques in Orange County-- and met with the imam there. Craig told him that he wanted to convert to Islam. The next day, after Friday prayers, Craig stood on a stage in front of hundreds of people and declared that he was now a Muslim with a new Muslim name-- Farouk al-Aziz. People who were in the mosque that day remember it well, the first time they saw this new convert, Farouk.
2006年8月的一个星期四，克雷格出现在尔湾伊斯兰中心——奥兰治县最大的清真寺之一——并会见了那里的阿訇。克雷格告诉他，他想皈依伊斯兰教。第二天，在周五主麻日礼拜后，克雷格站在数百人面前的台上，宣布自己现在是一名穆斯林，并起了一个新的穆斯林名字——法鲁克·阿齐兹（Farouk al-Aziz）。那天在清真寺的人都记得很清楚，他们第一次见到这个新皈依者“法鲁克”的情景。
Picture a 300-pound linebacker that has a ridiculously wide frame, and then huge, massive legs.
想象一个300磅的后卫，拥有极其宽大的骨架，还有巨大的腿部。
His biceps were just like my whole thigh, basically. It's just-- he was a big guy.
他的二头肌基本上就像我的整条大腿一样。他就是……他是个大块头。
At the beginning, I was kind of scared from him. [LAUGHS] He was kind of scary, to me, looking, yeah.
起初，我有点怕他。[笑] 对我来说他看起来有点吓人。
Over the next few weeks, Craig started showing up at the nearby 24 Hour Fitness, a gym where a lot of the guys from the Irvine mosque would work out. And when he wasn't at the gym, he was at the mosque. He attended prayer five times a day.
接下来的几周，克雷格开始出现在附近的24小时健身房，那是许多从尔湾清真寺出来的家伙们健身的地方。当他不在健身房时，他就在清真寺。他每天做五次礼拜。
One of the people who noticed Craig was an Egyptian guy named Ayman. He asked that I not use his last name.
其中一个注意到克雷格的人是名叫艾曼（Ayman）的埃及人。他要求我不要使用他的姓氏。
Every day, you would see him in the mosque-- every day you would see him. But he would be sitting alone. You don't know if he has friends, or if he is struggling to understand what's going on. You feel bad. This guy, he's new to Islam. Probably either he is afraid, or curious, or something. I don't know, you don't know. You just want to be as friendly as you can.
每天，你都会在清真寺见到他——每天都能看到。但他总是独自坐着。你不知道他是否有朋友，或者他是否在努力理解正在发生什么。你觉得很同情他。这个家伙，他是伊斯兰教的新手。可能要么他是害怕，要么是好奇，或者其他原因。我不知道，你不知道。你只是想尽可能友好地对待他。
Ayman lived in a house just around the corner from the mosque with a few other Egyptians. One day, he decided to introduce himself to Craig.
艾曼住在离清真寺转角处的一所房子里，和其他几个埃及人住在一起。有一天，他决定向克雷格自我介绍。
I believe it was after the Zuhr prayer, which is the one at 1:00 o'clock. I went to him, and I said, hey, salaam alaikum-- peace upon you, basically. And, hey, my name is Ayman.
我相信是在晌礼（Zuhr）之后，也就是下午1点那次。我走到他身边，说，嘿，祝你平安（salaam alaikum）。我是艾曼。
He says, it's been about four weeks, right? You're still here.
他说，已经过去大约四周了，对吧？你还在这儿。
Craig remembers this too.
克雷格也记得这个。
I said, yes. He said, well, usually people just-- new converts, after a few weeks, they just-- they leave. They fall by the wayside. I said, well, not me. I'm a real Muslim.
我说，是的。他说，好吧，通常新人皈依后几周就离开了。他们掉队了。我说，我不一样。我是个真正的穆斯林。
And I told him, here's my number. And I wrote my number on a piece of paper. If you have any question about anything, you know, like in your head about the religion, or if you need anything that I can help you with, I would love to.
我告诉他，这是我的电话。我在一张纸上写了号码。如果你有关于任何事情的问题，比如你脑子里对这个宗教的疑问，或者如果你需要任何我可以帮忙的事情，我很乐意。
And he said, well, you know, we're Egyptian. We get together on-- after, prayer on Fridays and during the weekends, and we all barbecue food together. Maybe you can come by, and we'll talk to you more about your faith and how you can grow as a Muslim. From there, when I went home, I thought, I'm really in.
他说，你知道，我们是埃及人。我们周五礼拜后和周末会聚在一起，一起烤肉。也许你可以过来，我们可以和你多聊聊你的信仰，以及如何作为一个穆斯林成长。从那时起，当我回家时，我想，我真的混进去了。
Craig's new friend Ayman lived with four unmarried Egyptian men, all in their late 20s or early 30s. One was an accountant. Another worked for a logistics company. There was a guy who worked in pharmaceuticals and an IT consultant. They each traveled occasionally, sometimes for work, or sometimes back home to Egypt. Craig says his FBI handler suspected the roommates might be a terrorist cell that would radicalize him, so he arrived at their house ready for anything.
克雷格的新朋友艾曼与四个未婚的埃及男人同住，他们都在20多岁或30出头。一个是会计，另一个在物流公司工作。还有一个从事制药业，一个是IT顾问。他们偶尔会出差，有时是为了工作，有时回埃及老家。克雷格说，他的FBI上线怀疑这些室友可能是一个会让他激进化的恐怖分子小组，所以他去他们家时做好了准备。
Well, first of all, they make some Egyptian food, which is very good-- delicious food. And we sit on the couch for about, maybe, a couple of hours, just had a conversation. And they would play their Xbox while we're having a conversation in a very competitive way.
嗯，首先，他们做了一些埃及菜，非常好吃。我们坐在沙发上大概聊了几个小时。当我们聊天时，他们会非常投入地玩他们的Xbox。
I was engaged at the time, but I used to play more Xbox than spending time with my fiancee. It's like 80% Xbox, and everything else comes second.
当时我订婚了，但我玩Xbox的时间比陪未婚妻的时间还多。大概80%的时间在玩Xbox，其他任何事情都排在后面。
That's Ayman again. He and his friends were ridiculously obsessed with Xbox. They'd play tournaments for five hours a day, and they only played one game.
那是艾曼。他和他的朋友们对Xbox简直着迷。他们每天打比赛五个小时，而且只玩一个游戏。
FIFA Soccer. That was something-- we played a lot of FIFA. We still play a lot of FIFA.
《FIFA足球》。那真是……我们玩了很多FIFA。我们现在还在玩。
Yasser AbdelRahim was one of Ayman's roommates, a tall, athletic guy who worked as a tech consultant. He'd lived in the US for about 10 years. Yasser and Ayman considered their house a brotherhood, but as he told me and my producer Bryan Reed, not really the militant terror cell kind Craig was looking for.
亚瑟·阿卜杜勒拉希姆（Yasser AbdelRahim）是艾曼的室友之一，一个高大健壮的家伙，担任技术顾问。他在美国住了大约10年。亚瑟和艾曼把他们的家视为兄弟会，但正如他告诉我和我的制作人布莱恩·里德（Bryan Reed）的那样，那并不是克雷格寻找的那种好战的恐怖组织。
We'd all just hang out together, and a lot of my friends would actually come in and say, this is the frat house, right? But, obviously, we didn't drink, so like--
我们只是聚在一起，很多我的朋友其实会进来，然后说，这是兄弟会宿舍，对吧？但是，显然，我们不喝酒，所以……
A frat house without alcohol.
一个不喝酒的兄弟会宿舍。
A kosher frat house, yes. [LAUGHS]
一个符合教规的兄弟会宿舍，是的。[笑]
Craig's plan worked. Yasser and Ayman started inviting him over more and more. They'd hang out together, get coffee, go to the movies. When Craig got sick, they went to his house to keep him company. They bought him books about Islam and brought them back gifts from their trips to Egypt. Here's Ayman, and then Yasser.
克雷格的计划成功了。亚瑟和艾曼开始邀请他越来越多地过来。他们聚在一起，喝咖啡，看电影。当克雷格生病时，他们去他家陪他。他们给他买关于伊斯兰教的书，并从埃及旅行回来带礼物给他。这是艾曼，然后是亚瑟。
He was a super cool guy. You know, he initiated conversation. We'd talk about stuff.
他是一个超级酷的家伙。你知道，他主动发起对话。我们谈论各种事情。
He was very comfortable around us. He was very cool around us. He would joke around. He would tell us about what he did, some of the issues that he was going through. He said he was going through some rough patches from a family perspective, going through a divorce.
他在我们面前很自在。他很酷。他会开玩笑。他会告诉我们他做了什么，他正在经历的一些问题。他说由于家庭原因，他正经历一些艰难时期，正在离婚。
We tried not to speak in Arabic as much when he's around, because we didn't want to give him any feeling that he's uncomfortable or anything like that.
我们在他身边时尽量少说阿拉伯语，因为我们不想让他感到不舒服。
We talked about the gym. We went and worked out together.
我们谈论健身房。我们一起去健身。
Obviously, when you see a big bulky guy, you know what I mean, that's just like, that's very cool. I barely can lift 5 pounds.
显然，当你看到一个强壮的大个子时，你知道我的意思，那很酷。我连5磅的重量都举不动。
We'd watch TV. Sometimes, we'd watch Arabic movies, because he'd be interested in actually seeing some of that.
我们会看电视。有时我们看阿拉伯语电影，因为他会对看这些感兴趣。
We never treated him as an outsider.
我们从没把他当外人。
So he seemed like one of the boys.
所以他看起来就像我们的一员。
But Craig was at work-- watching, taking notes, and recording with a hidden microphone.
但克雷格正在工作——观察、记录，并用隐藏的麦克风录音。
It'd be on the whole day. I would get into my car in my garage, I would turn on the device, and I would say something like, Farouk al-Aziz, May 4, 2012, 5:45 AM, and I am hot-- meaning it's beginning.
它整天开着。我会进入车库的车里，打开设备，然后说点什么，比如：“法鲁克·阿齐兹，2012年5月4日，凌晨5:45，我进入状态了”——意味着行动开始了。
The FBI has publicly confirmed that Craig recorded audio and video during this operation. That means, presumably, the smack the Egyptians talked during Xbox tournaments, the discussions of movies and their personal lives, the exercise tips that Craig gave them at the gym. The Egyptians would play pickup soccer on the weekends with a bunch of other Muslim guys. Craig went to some of these games, but he never played. Instead, Craig says he used the opportunity to jot down license plate numbers and film the games so his handlers could see who associated with whom. According to Craig, he also brought his handlers things from the Egyptians' house that might have their DNA or fingerprints.
FBI已经公开证实，克雷格在此行动中录制了音频和视频。这意味着，大概包括埃及人在Xbox比赛中说的垃圾话，关于电影和私人生活的讨论，克雷格在健身房给他们的锻炼建议。埃及人周末会和一群其他穆斯林小伙子踢野球。克雷格去过几次比赛，但他从不踢。相反，克雷格说他利用这个机会记下车牌号码并拍摄比赛，以便他的上线查看谁与谁往来。据克雷格说，他还带给上线一些可能带有埃及人DNA或指纹的东西。
They instructed me to get-- because Ayman smoked-- a cigarette butt from his ashtray in his room, and certain items from his bathroom, like a toothpaste tube.
他们指示我获取——因为艾曼抽烟——他房间烟灰缸里的烟头，以及他浴室里的某些物品，比如牙膏管。
So you would sneak around their house and steal these things from their rooms?
所以你会潜入他们的房子，从他们的房间里偷这些东西？
Yes.
是的。
Meeting Ayman and Yasser, it was hard to imagine why the FBI was monitoring them. They just seemed like normal guys. The FBI, of course, wouldn't talk about the case, and they wouldn't even talk in a general way, separate from this case, about how they choose who they're going to investigate. So I called Trevor Aaronson to help me make sense of Operation Flex. He's an investigative journalist who's analyzed over 500 FBI terrorism convictions looking at how informants are used to find suspects, surveil them, and build cases. I told Trevor what Craig said-- that the FBI went into the Muslim community without any specific suspects. Trevor said that's possible, but it's also possible that Craig wasn't told who the targets were.
见到艾曼和亚瑟，很难想象FBI为什么会监视他们。他们看起来就像普通人。FBI当然不会谈论这个案子，甚至不会在脱离本案的一般层面下讨论他们如何选择调查对象。所以我打电话给特雷弗·阿伦森（Trevor Aaronson）帮我理清“Flex行动”。他是一位调查记者，分析了超过500起FBI恐怖主义定罪案例，研究线人如何被用于发现嫌疑人、监视他们并建立案件。我告诉特雷弗克雷格所说的——FBI在没有特定嫌疑人的情况下进入穆斯林社区。特雷弗说这是可能的，但也可能是克雷格不知道目标是谁。
It's possible that the FBI had information that Craig isn't aware of. In the cases we've looked at, it's really uncommon that the FBI would spend lots of time with someone who was so unfruitful. If they're spending months and months, and all they're doing is playing soccer, the FBI will move on. If Craig was spending that much time with them, it's worth noting that most likely, they had enough for what they call a predicate, which is a reason that they were investigating them-- that there was a phone call that was overheard, there was some kind of correspondence with someone overseas that the FBI is monitoring that made the FBI agents suspicious of this particular group.
FBI可能掌握了克雷格不知道的信息。在我们研究的案件中，FBI花大量时间在一个毫无成果的人身上是非常罕见的。如果他们花费数月时间，而他们所做的只是踢足球，FBI会转向下一个。如果克雷格花那么多时间在他们身上，值得注意的是，很可能他们已经有了所谓的“谓词”，即他们调查他们的原因——比如窃听到一个电话，或者与海外某人的某种通信，让FBI特工对这个特定群体产生了怀疑。
In addition to Trevor, my producer and I talked to five long-time FBI agents now retired who all oversaw informants. They couldn't comment on Operation Flex specifically, and none of them knew firsthand about these Egyptian guys, but they gave us similar theories. Basically, they said if the FBI has even the smallest reason to suspect you, a reason you might not even be aware of yourself, they have to check you out.
除了特雷弗，我和我的制作人还采访了五位现在已退休的长期FBI特工，他们都曾监管过线人。他们无法就“Flex行动”发表具体评论，而且他们中没有人直接了解这些埃及年轻人，但他们给了我们类似的理论。基本上，他们说如果FBI有哪怕最微小的理由怀疑你，一个你甚至可能自己都不知道的理由，他们就必须调查你。
Maybe you happened to phone someone the FBI is monitoring. Maybe they got a bad tip. One of the ex-FBI agents said to me, do innocent people get investigated? Sure, every day. They can't weed them out without looking at them. Though one agent said it was possible that this was a case that just went awry, that was badly managed and didn't follow FBI protocols.
也许你碰巧给FBI正在监视的某人打了电话。也许他们收到了糟糕的举报。其中一位前FBI探员对我说，无辜的人会受到调查吗？当然，每天都在发生。他们如果不进行观察就无法筛选出他们。尽管一位探员表示，这个案子可能只是出岔子了，管理不善且没有遵循FBI协议。
Months passed. People noticed that Craig was acting more devout. He began reciting prayers aloud, dressing in traditional robes, and showing up so early for 5:00 AM prayers that he'd get there before the person who unlocked the mosque every morning. They also noticed something else.
几个月过去了。人们注意到克雷格表现得越来越虔诚。他开始大声背诵祈祷词，穿着传统长袍，并在凌晨5点的祈祷中出现得如此早，以至于他每天早上都在清真寺开门人到达之前就到了。他们还注意到另一件事。
Slowly and surely enough some during some times when we're having coffee came the question of jihad.
慢慢地，确实，在喝咖啡的时候，出现了关于“圣战”（Jihad）的问题。
Yasser, one of the Egyptians, had actually been asked questions about jihad before. Non-Muslims bring it up with him sometimes. He'll be on a plane, and the person next to him will ask about it.
埃及人之一亚瑟实际上以前就被问过关于“圣战”的问题。非穆斯林有时会和他提起。他在飞机上，旁边的人会问起这件事。
So he and his friends told Craig what they always tell people-- that jihad isn't what you see on the news. Jihad is really about each person's internal striving to be a good Muslim. It's not holy war. Here's Ayman.
所以他和他的朋友们告诉克雷格他们总是告诉别人的话——“圣战”不是你在新闻里看到的那样。真正的“圣战”是关于每个人内心努力成为一个好穆斯林。那不是圣战。这是艾曼的话。
But the reality is, if I'm new to Islam, I would be very curious about this stuff, too. I would be very curious about this stuff. You know, that's what the media talks about all the time. So he must be very curious. If you mention Islam, then-- I think there was a survey, if you mention Islam, the second thing that you think about in the American society was terrorist.
但现实是，如果我是伊斯兰教的新手，我也会对这些东西非常好奇。我会对这些非常好奇。你知道，媒体一直在谈论这个。所以他一定非常好奇。如果你提到伊斯兰教，那么——我想有一项调查，如果你提到伊斯兰教，在美国社会中你想到的第二件事就是恐怖分子。
So for me, it was somehow normal, if you look at it from a curiosity viewpoint. But it wasn't normal how obsessed he was with it, until when we start being, this guy is-- there's something very, very [BLEEP] up about this person. He just would bring these odd things in the middle of the conversation, out of nowhere.
所以对我来说，如果你从好奇心的角度来看，这在某种程度上是正常的。但他对它的痴迷程度并不正常，直到我们开始觉得，这个家伙——这个人身上有什么非常、非常“操蛋”的事情。他会没来由地在谈话中间插入这些奇怪的东西。
For instance, the guys would be talking about food or sports.
例如，大家可能在谈论食物或运动。
But yet, he would always bring politics into the conversation-- jihad, suicide bomber. So what do you want to-- for example, I'm being sarcastic-- what do you want to eat, Farouk? So what do you think about Hosni Mubarak, you know what I mean? He-- just out of nowhere.
但他总是把政治带入对话——“圣战”、自杀式炸弹袭击者。所以你想——例如，我在讽刺——你想吃什么，法鲁克？你觉得胡斯尼·穆巴拉克怎么样，你知道我的意思吗？他——就是没来由地。
Craig talked to his Arabic teacher, Mohamed Elsisy about his new obsession, too.
克雷格也和他那个阿拉伯语老师穆罕默德·埃尔西西（Mohamed Elsisy）谈论了他的新痴迷。
He invited me once to lunch, yes, and he focused the topic in the lunch about jihad. And I keep turning his attention into the essence of Islam, and he kept again bringing it back to jihad. And he kept asking about jihad over, and over, and over. And I told him, Farouk, get over it. Get over it. Get over it.
他有一次请我吃午饭，是的，他把话题集中在午饭上的“圣战”。我一直在把他的注意力转向伊斯兰教的本质，但他又不断地把它带回“圣战”。他不断地问关于“圣战”的问题，反复不断。我告诉他，法鲁克，算了吧。算了吧。算了吧。
It alarmed all of them. At one point, Yasser confronted Farouk-- that is, Craig.
这让他们所有人都感到担忧。有一次，亚瑟当面质问了法鲁克——也就是克雷格。
I even told him, like, Farouk, this needs to stop, because this is not the right direction. This is not what Islam is about. So if somebody is teaching this, let me know, because we need to correct that immediately, right?
我甚至告诉他，法鲁克，这必须停止，因为这不是正确的方向。伊斯兰教不是这个意思。所以如果有人在教这些，请告诉我，因为我们需要立即纠正这一点，对吧？
And did he seem receptive?
他表现得能接受吗？
He did. He said he did, right? And I told him-- I told him, at this point, people are starting to get to wonder about what's going on, where you're learning this stuff from, right? So we need to understand. And he was like, yeah, I'm not going to talk to anybody about this. I don't know; maybe I was reading some incorrect stuff.
他表现得接受了，对吧？我告诉他——我告诉他，在这一点上，人们开始怀疑到底发生了什么，你从哪里学到的这些东西，对吧？所以我们需要理解。他当时就像是，是的，我不会和任何人谈论这个。我不知道；也许我读了一些不正确的东西。
But Craig didn't listen. He didn't stop talking about jihad. He says this is what the FBI wanted, because, he says, he was great at it.
但克雷格没有听。他没有停止谈论“圣战”。他说这就是FBI想要的，因为他说他很擅长这个。
I would have to, in a very strategic way, get their views on jihad. And I got so good at it, in their view, that they wanted to enhance it. So I was to speak to, I think, 10 Muslims a day regarding jihad.
我不得不以一种非常战略性的方式，获得他们对“圣战”的看法。在他们看来，我做得非常好，以至于他们想加强它。所以我每天要和大概10个穆斯林谈论关于“圣战”的话题。
Since the FBI isn't commenting, I ran this by Trevor Aaronson, the journalist who's examined about 500 counter-terrorism cases, to see if it was possible. He said that in all of those hundreds of cases, he's never heard of a quota like this. The FBI agents I spoke with hadn't either. Though Trevor says that once a sting operation gets going, it's common for undercover agents and informants to bait suspects by asking them about jihad.
由于FBI没有发表评论，我把这个情况告诉了特雷弗·阿伦森，那个研究过大约500起反恐案件的记者，看看这是否可能。他说在所有那几百起案件中，他从未听说过这样的配额。我交谈过的FBI特工也没听说过。尽管特雷弗说，一旦卧底行动开始，卧底和线人通过询问嫌疑人关于“圣战”的问题来引诱他们是常见的。
That happens in almost every undercover sting operation. I can tell you that in many of the cases I've looked at, that's mentioned in the criminal affidavit in some way. And I think when that's submitted at trial, that's a really damning piece of evidence for juries today.
这在几乎所有的卧底引诱行动中都会发生。我可以告诉你，在我看过的许多案例中，这在刑事宣誓书中以某种方式提到过。而且我认为当这在审判中提交时，这对今天的陪审团来说是一个非常有力的证据。
Craig took this strategy and ran with it. Mohamed, the Arabic teacher, heard complaints from his friends.
克雷格采取了这个策略并付诸行动。阿拉伯语老师穆罕默德听到了朋友们的抱怨。
It was to the limit that one of them told me he keeps calling him by phone and keep saying to him, (WHISPERING) jihad, jihad. I was like, you know, wait a minute!
到了这个地步，其中一个告诉我，他不断地打电话给他，并不断对他重复：（低声）圣战，圣战。我当时就像，你知道，等等！
He would whisper jihad in the phone?
他会对着电话低声说“圣战”？
Yeah, in the phone.
是的，在电话里。
I asked Craig, did that happen?
我问克雷格，这发生了吗？
Probably. I'm not denying it. I may have been-- we had a conversation or something, and I had done something ridiculous like that. But I don't deny it. I'm sure I probably did, OK?
可能吧。我并不否认。我可能……我们有过一次谈话什么的，我做了一些像那样荒谬的事情。但我并不否认。我肯定我可能做了，好吧？
What were you trying to accomplish with that?
你试图通过那样达到什么目的？
Whatever individual heard that, and they didn't quickly report me, they're automatically a suspect. Every single conversation is a conversation that the FBI or a prosecutor can say, well, you heard him say this numerous times, and yet you didn't do the following.
任何听到那个的人，如果他们没有迅速报告我，他们就自动成为嫌疑人。每一次谈话都是FBI或检察官可以利用的谈话，他们会说，好吧，你听他说了无数次，但你却没有采取后续行动。
And so that's what you were trying to do?
所以这就是你试图做的？
Of course.
当然。
If you didn't think Craig could get any less subtle, here's another tactic he would try.
如果你不认为克雷格还能表现得更不含蓄，这里有另一个他会尝试的策略。
I'd say, let's meet tomorrow afternoon at the gym. We'll work out together. I'll teach you some things about how to get your forearms shaped a little better, your biceps stronger and bigger. And at these workouts, I would ask very sensitive question regarding Islam. For example--
我会说，明天下午在健身房见面吧。我们一起锻炼。我会教你一些关于如何让前臂形状更好，让二头肌更强壮和更大的东西。在这些锻炼中，我会询问关于伊斯兰教的非常敏感的问题。例如——
So what do you think about Osama bin Laden?
那么你觉得本·拉登怎么样？
Ayman was working on his biceps when Craig asked him this.
艾曼正在练二头肌时，克雷格问了他这个问题。
I'm like, dude, OK, Osama bin Laden is a bad guy. He's a mother[BLEEP], you know what I mean? All what we are suffering from right now is because of Osama bin Laden. And your question right now is because of Osama bin Laden, you know what I mean? All of these new laws that they start acting about just searching, you know and sticking their finger in you [BLEEP] is because of Osama bin Laden. So you tell him, yeah, you know, Osama bin Laden is the bad guy.
我当时就像，伙计，好吧，本·拉登是个坏人。他是个他妈的混蛋，你知道我的意思吗？我们现在遭受的一切都是因为本·拉登。你现在的问题也是因为本·拉登，你知道我的意思吗？所有这些他们开始实行的关于搜查的新法律，你懂的，把手指塞进你屁股里……是因为本·拉登。所以你告诉他，是的，你知道，本·拉登是个坏人。
One day, a guy named Riaz Surti showed up at the gym with a friend Riaz had owned the halal KFC/Taco Bell nearby. Craig hopped off a stationary bike and introduced himself to Riaz as a fellow Muslim. Here's Riaz.
有一天，一个叫里亚兹·苏尔蒂（Riaz Surti）的家伙带了一个朋友出现在健身房。里亚兹在附近拥有一家清真KFC/塔可钟。克雷格从固定自行车上跳下来，以同为穆斯林的身份向里亚兹介绍自己。这是里亚兹。
Then I left. I left to go and stretch out. Then I came back, and then he leans to us, and then he says, you know, I met the Sheikh in Afghanistan?
然后我离开了。我离开去伸展一下。然后我回来了，然后他向我们靠过来，然后他说，你知道，我在阿富汗见过谢赫（Sheikh）吗？
"The Sheik?"
“谢赫？”
The Sheikh. He said, yeah, I met the big guy, or the Sheikh in Afghanistan.
谢赫。他说，是的，我在阿富汗见过那个大人物，或者说谢赫。
What did you think when he said that?
当他说那话时你怎么想的？
We knew that he was referring to Osama bin Laden. He was bragging. He was smiling that he met the Sheikh, yeah. It just became very clear to us.
我们知道他指的是本·拉登。他在吹牛。他在微笑着说他在阿富汗见过谢赫，是的。这在我们看来非常清楚。
Craig told us he has never been to Afghanistan, but he was trying to see if these guys at the gym who he'd never met thought it would be cool to hang out with Osama bin Laden. They didn't think that would be cool. So instead, Riaz says, he wanted to get Craig to leave him alone. So every time he saw him, he would tell him the dirtiest jokes he could come up with.
克雷格告诉我们他从未去过阿富汗，但他试图看看这些他在健身房从未见过的人是否觉得和本·拉登一起玩很酷。他们不觉得这很酷。所以相反，里亚兹说，他想让克雷格离开他。所以每次他见到他，他都会告诉他他能想到的最脏的笑话。
I didn't want him to think I was a good Muslim. I just felt like his goal was to like to get us involved with something that we weren't involved with.
我不想让他以为我是个好穆斯林。我只是觉得他的目标是让我们参与到我们没有参与的事情中。
What did you tell him?
你告诉他什么了？
Like did you hear about the doctor who was having sex with his patients? And he said, no. And I said, he's a very interesting doctor. And then, he looked at me. He was a veterinarian.
就像你听说那个与病人发生性关系的医生了吗？他说，没有。我说，他是一个非常有趣的医生。然后，他看着我。他是个兽医。
It worked. Craig left him alone after that. About eight months into Operation Flex, Craig says his handlers told him to start talking to people about an actual terrorist plot, a plan to blow up buildings in Southern California. That happens in lots of FBI stings-- the informant suggests the plot to the suspect, not the other way around-- according to Trevor Aaronson again, who studied hundreds of terrorism convictions.
这奏效了。那之后克雷格就没再找他。在“Flex行动”进行到大约八个月时，克雷格说他的上线告诉他开始和人们谈论一个实际的恐怖阴谋，一个炸毁南加州建筑的计划。这在许多FBI的引诱行动中都会发生——线人向嫌疑人建议阴谋，而不是反过来——根据特雷弗·阿伦森再次提到的说法，他研究了数百起恐怖主义定罪。
Of about 500 terrorism cases since 9/11, about 50 defendants have been involved in cases where the informant came up with the idea and provided all of the means.
自“9·11”以来的大约500起恐怖主义案件中，约有50名被告涉及线人提出想法并提供所有手段的案件。
But ex-FBI agents I talked to said that in the well-run operation, the informant is not supposed to suggest the plot out of the blue. First, the suspect would have to declare his intention to commit an act of violence. Without that, the whole case could get thrown out of court as entrapment.
但我交谈过的前FBI探员说，在管理良好的行动中，线人不应该突然提出阴谋。首先，嫌疑人必须宣布他实施暴力行为的意图。如果没有这一点，整个案件可能会因为“诱捕”而在法庭上被驳回。
The person Craig suggested his plot to was a guy named Ahmad Niazi. Niazi is the only person we know of that Craig helped catch, the only person the FBI arrested as a result of Operation Flex. Craig had met Niazi one night at the Irvine mosque. Mohamed, Craig's Arabic teacher, introduced them.
克雷格建议阴谋的对象是一个叫艾哈迈德·尼亚兹（Ahmad Niazi）的家伙。尼亚兹是我们知道的克雷格帮助抓获的唯一一个人，也是FBI因“Flex行动”逮捕的唯一一个人。克雷格是在尔湾清真寺的一个晚上见到尼亚兹的。克雷格的阿拉伯语老师穆罕默德介绍了他们。
Niazi was a family man, very different from the Egyptian Xbox players. He had a wife and two young kids and taught at a nearby language school. Niazi grew up in Afghanistan, but he had lived in California for eight years. He and Craig went out for coffee, and they hit it off. They started hanging out a lot, sometimes with Mohamed.
尼亚兹是个顾家的男人，与那些玩Xbox的埃及人非常不同。他有妻子和两个年幼的孩子，在附近的一所语言学校教书。尼亚兹在阿富汗长大，但在加州住了八年。他和克雷格一起出去喝咖啡，他们一见如故。他们开始频繁交往，有时和穆罕默德在一起。
One Friday, the three of them were driving to a mosque where Mohamed was scheduled to give a sermon. Niazi didn't want to do an interview for our story, but here's Mohamed.
一个星期五，他们三个开车去一个清真寺，穆罕默德定在那里做布道。尼亚兹不想为我们的故事做采访，但这是穆罕默德的叙述。
Niazi was sitting in the back seat, and Farouk was sitting in the passenger, and I was driving.
尼亚兹坐在后座，法鲁克坐在副驾驶，我开车。
And here's Craig, a.k.a. Farouk.
这是克雷格，也就是法鲁克。
And I started to bring up, what should we really do as Muslims now that our brothers and sisters are being blown up in Afghanistan and Iraq?
我开始提起，现在我们的兄弟姐妹在阿富汗和伊拉克被炸死，我们作为穆斯林到底应该做什么？
And I told him, Farouk, we are living in Irvine, the most peaceful city in the whole America. [LAUGHS] He's like, you know, I just don't like the way that American government is handling situations outside and stuff. And I was like, OK, and what?
我告诉他，法鲁克，我们住在尔湾，整个美国最和平的城市。[笑] 他就像，你知道，我就是不喜欢美国政府处理外面局势的方式什么的。我当时就像，好的，然后呢？
Are we supposed to just stay here, watch our national championship games, play Xbox and everything else, while our brothers are being killed?
我们是不是应该就在这儿待着，看我们的全国锦标赛，玩Xbox和其他一切，当我们的兄弟被杀时？
And he starts talking about some jihad.
然后他开始谈论一些“圣战”。
I mean, I became very aggressive.
我的意思是我变得非常有攻击性。
And we told him, Farouk, what are you trying to get into, exactly?
我们告诉他，法鲁克，你到底想钻进什么东西里？
I said, we should carry out a terrorist attack in this country, because I'm tired just staying around doing nothing. I've got access to weapons. I know how to do things. We should bomb something.
我说，我们应该在这个国家进行一次恐怖袭击，因为我厌倦了只是待着无所事事。我有获取武器的途径。我知道怎么做。我们应该炸点什么。
Silence was out there in the car. I didn't say a word until we arrived to the mosque. I refused to talk at all. The first thing that came into my mind, that I thought that he is a straight shot terrorist. And that at that point, I felt scared from him. He scared me.
车里一片寂静。直到我们到达清真寺我一句话也没说。我拒绝谈话。我脑子里想到的第一件事就是，我想他是个不折不扣的恐怖分子。在那个点上，我感到害怕。他吓到我了。
Mohamed glanced into the rearview mirror and saw Niazi staring back at him. He looked shocked. Craig's head was down. He was now playing with his phone. No one said anything for the remaining 20 minutes of the ride to the mosque. The drive back home was the same.
穆罕默德扫了一眼后视镜，看到尼亚兹盯着他。他看起来很震惊。克雷格低下头。他在摆弄他的手机。在剩下的20分钟去清真寺的车程中，没人说话。回家的路上也是一样。
After they parted ways with Craig, Mohamed and Niazi talked about what had just happened. They decided they had to do something, so they did what all Americans are supposed to do in this situation, what law enforcement officials tell us we should do when someone says he has access to weapons and wants to use them. They reported Craig to the FBI as a potential terrorist.
在与克雷格分开后，穆罕默德和尼亚兹谈论了刚才发生的事情。他们决定必须做点什么，所以他们做了所有美国人在这种情况下应该做的事，也就是执法官员告诉我们当某人说他有获取武器途径并想使用它们时我们应该做的事。他们向FBI报告了克雷格，称他为潜在的恐怖分子。
Coming up, what happens, exactly, when you turn in someone to the FBI who is working for the FBI? Sam Black's story continues in a minute from Chicago Public Radio, when our program continues.
稍后，当你向FBI举报一个实际上为FBI工作的人时，到底会发生什么？萨姆·布莱克的报道将在来自芝加哥公共广播电台的节目继续后一分钟继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today's program, "The Convert," the story of an FBI undercover operation from 2006 that went very-- badly is, I think, a fair way to say it, and the uneasy relationship between some Muslims and the FBI, and why that might be. And as I said at the top of the show, we first ran today's program back in 2012, and we're rerunning it today because the case that it documents was argued at the Supreme Court last month.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目，“皈依者”，讲述了2006年一次非常——糟糕是我想到的一个恰当词——的FBI卧底行动的故事，以及一些穆斯林与FBI之间不安的关系，以及为什么会这样。正如我在节目开头所说，我们第一次播出今天的节目是在2012年，今天重播是因为它记录的案件上个月在美国最高法院进行了辩论。
It's hard to say what, exactly, constitutes failure if you're a government informant, but I think that being turned over to authorities as a possible terrorist yourself by the people who you think are terrorists, that's got to be on the list, right? That's not good. Sam Black picks up our story where we left off.
很难说如果身为政府线人到底什么构成失败，但我想被那些你认为是恐怖分子的人举报给当局，称你自己是可能的恐怖分子，那一定在名单上，对吧？那可不好。萨姆·布莱克接续我们的故事。
So Mohamed and Niazi wanted to report Craig to the FBI, but they weren't sure who to call or how to do it. They reached out to Hussam Ayloush. Hussam is director of the Council on American-Islamic Relations in Southern California, known as CAIR, and a well-known member of the Muslim community there. Just hours after the car ride, he got a phone call from Mohamed. Here's Hussam.
所以穆罕默德和尼亚兹想向FBI举报克雷格，但他们不确定打给谁或怎么做。他们联系了胡萨姆·艾卢什（Hussam Ayloush）。胡萨姆是美国-伊斯兰关系委员会（CAIR）南加州的主任，也是当地穆斯林社区的一位知名人士。就在车程后几个小时，他接到了穆罕默德的电话。这是胡萨姆。
He was terrified. I mean, the guy didn't know what to do. He was so nervous. He told me, I know you deal with the FBI, and I know you work with police. You know, what do I do now?
他吓坏了。那个家伙不知道该怎么办。他太紧张了。他告诉我，我知道你和FBI打交道，我也知道你和警察工作。你知道，我现在该怎么办？
Mohamed was with Niazi. They were both afraid that if Craig went ahead with his plot, they would somehow be responsible.
穆罕默德和尼亚兹在一起。他们都很害怕，如果克雷格继续他的阴谋，他们会以某种方式负责。
He passed the phone to Niazi, who was also panicking like crazy. I mean, both of them, they didn't know what to do. So I told them, don't worry about it. Calm down, you're not responsible for anything. You're doing the right thing.
他把电话给了尼亚兹，尼亚兹也惊慌失措。他们两个都不知道该怎么办。所以我告诉他们，别担心。冷静下来，你们不对任何事情负责。你们在做正确的事。
You're calling the authorities. So even, if the guy is planning on anything, you have nothing to worry about. You're not accomplices.
你们在联系当局。所以，即使那个家伙正在计划什么，你们也没什么可担心的。你们不是同谋。
So what did you think was going on when you got this call?
当你接到这个电话时，你认为发生了什么？
There are three possibilities. Either he is recruited by al-Qaeda, or he's a lone wolf doing things on his own, or he's doing it for somebody else as an entrapment. Either way, it's bad news.
有三种可能。要么他被基地组织招募，要么他是独自行动的“孤狼”，要么他为了诱捕在为别人做这件事。无论哪种方式，都是坏消息。
Hussam told Mohamed and Niazi that he would call the FBI. For years, he'd been attending monthly meetings with agents who'd hoped to build a good relationship with the Muslim community, and he was friends with Steve Tidwell, the head of the FBI's LA Office. Hussam had actually organized the outreach meeting you heard about earlier, the one more Tidwell promised that the FBI wouldn't send people into mosques unannounced. So Hussam called Tidwell on his cell phone and told him what had happened to Mohamed and Niazi. They thought this guy in the car might be serious. Again, here's Hussam.
胡萨姆告诉穆罕默德和尼亚兹他会打给FBI。多年来，他一直参加与探员的月度会议，他们希望与穆斯林社区建立良好的关系，他是FBI洛杉矶办公室负责人史蒂夫·蒂德威尔的朋友。胡萨姆实际上组织了你之前听到的那次外联会议，那次会议上，蒂德威尔承诺FBI不会未经通知派遣人员进入清真寺。所以胡萨姆用手机打给蒂德威尔，告诉他穆罕默德和尼亚兹身上发生了什么。他们认为车里的这个家伙可能是认真的。这是胡萨姆。
They said, well, you know, thanks, Hussam. You're doing the right thing. Thank these gentlemen. This is exactly why we're so proud of working with the Muslim community. And I did mention this. He's a white guy, a white convert in Irvine. He said, oh. That's what he said, oh, OK, thank you, Hussam. That's great information. And we'll let you know what happens.
他们说，好吧，你知道，谢谢，胡萨姆。你们做的是正确的事。感谢这些绅士。这就是为什么我们为与穆斯林社区工作感到如此自豪。而且我提到了这一点。他是个白人，尔湾的一个白人皈依者。他说，哦。他就是那么说的，哦，好的，谢谢，胡萨姆。那是很棒的信息。我们会让你知道发生了什么。
I said, wait, wait, wait, don't you need his name-- because I had his name-- and I have his address, because they knew where he lived. They said, well, you know, don't worry about it. We work closely with Irvine PD, and we'll take care of it from here. Don't worry about it. That's when my doubts started playing in my head, like-- I felt there was something strange.
我说，等等，等等，等等，你们不需要他的名字吗——因为我有他的名字——而且我有他的地址，因为他们知道他住在哪里。他们说，好吧，你知道，别担心。我们与尔湾警察局密切合作，我们会从这里开始处理。别担心。就在那时，我的疑虑开始出现在我脑海中，就像——我觉得有些奇怪。
Tidwell wouldn't speak to me for this story, so I don't know what he thought when his own informant was reported to him as a terrorist. But not long after this phone call, the FBI launched an investigation into Craig-- which, no matter how you look at it, was a very strange undertaking. FBI agents were going around asking questions about an FBI informant, treating him as an actual suspect they were investigating. FBI Special Agents not only interviewed Mohamed and Niazi. They also questioned other people who had been hanging out with Craig.
蒂德威尔没有接受我的采访，所以我不知道当他自己的线人被举报为恐怖分子时他在想什么。但在那个电话后不久，FBI对克雷格展开了调查——无论你怎么看，这都是一个非常奇怪的举动。FBI特工四处询问关于一个FBI线人的问题，把他当作他们正在调查的实际嫌疑人来对待。FBI特别探员不仅采访了穆罕默德和尼亚兹，他们还盘问了其他与克雷格混在一起的人。
I talked to five people who willingly took part in these interviews. At the time, they thought they were helping catch a dangerous person. Mohamed and Niazi even went in front of a judge in Orange County Superior Court and got a restraining order against Craig so that he couldn't come within 200 yards of the mosque. But looking back, the people the FBI interviewed told me there was something weird about the way the agents were acting through this whole ordeal. They just didn't seem that concerned. Yasser, one of the Egyptians, said it wasn't what he imagined would happen when you call in the feds on a possible terrorist.
我采访了五位自愿参加这些访谈的人。当时，他们以为自己在帮忙抓捕一个危险分子。穆罕默德和尼亚兹甚至来到奥兰治县高等法院法官面前，对克雷格申请了限制令，使他不能靠近清真寺200码以内。但回想起来，FBI采访的人告诉我，在这整场磨难中，探员们的行为有些奇怪。他们看起来根本不那么关心。亚瑟，埃及人之一，说当他打电话举报可能的恐怖分子时，这不是他想象中会发生的事情。
My picture in my head is, if you go and bring that up, it's on. Let's go, let's find this person. Let's make sure we're stopping them. They would be at his door immediately-- 30 cars, blah, blah, movie style-- kind of like break in, let's get this guy. That wasn't the reaction, right? That wasn't the reaction we were getting.
我脑子里的画面是，如果你去提出这件事，那肯定是真的。走吧，让我们找到这个人。让我们确保我们在阻止他。他们会立即出现在他门口——30辆车，巴拉巴拉，电影风格——就像那种破门而入，我们要抓住这个家伙。那不是反应，对吧？那不是我们得到的反应。
The agents did ask questions about Craig-- how often did he come to the mosque? Who else did he hang out with? What kinds of things did he say? But with Yasser and others, they gradually began to ask more personal questions. How many times did you talk with Farouk about jihad? What do you think jihad means? When did you come to the United States? Again, Yasser.
探员确实问了关于克雷格的问题——他多久来一次清真寺？他还和谁混在一起？他说过什么样的话？但对亚瑟和其他人，他们逐渐开始问更多私人问题。你和法鲁克谈论“圣战”多少次？你认为“圣战”是什么意思？你什么时候来到美国的？亚瑟说。
These guys knew exactly what was going on. They knew he was their informant. I think it was just another way for them to get us in and talk to them.
这些家伙完全知道发生了什么。他们知道他是他们的线人。我认为这只是他们让我们进去和他们交谈的另一种方式。
Some people were visited by the FBI more than once, like Mohamed. One day, FBI agents surprised him at his house. He asked them how the investigation into Farouk was going. They told him Farouk was a dangerous guy and he would be in trouble soon. But Mohamed says the agents were there to talk about someone else.
有些人被FBI拜访了不止一次，比如穆罕默德。有一天，FBI探员在他家让他感到惊讶。他问他们对法鲁克的调查进行得怎么样了。他们告诉他法鲁克是个危险的家伙，他很快就会有麻烦。但穆罕默德说探员去那是为了谈论别人。
They asked me a couple of questions about Ahmad Niazi, how much information I know about him. And I told him, I don't know anything about Ahmad Niazi except that he is a person that comes and prays in the mosque, and I know him through the community. I didn't know him before that, and I don't know very much information about him.
他们问了我几个关于艾哈迈德·尼亚兹的问题，我对他了解多少信息。我告诉他，我除了知道他是来清真寺礼拜的人，通过社区认识他之外，我对艾哈迈德·尼亚兹一无所知。我之前并不认识他，对他也没有太多信息。
They said, we just wanted to collect more information about that person. I told him, I told you what I know about him. That's all.
他们说，我们只是想收集更多关于那个人的信息。我告诉他，我已经告诉你我对他了解的情况了。就是这样。
This was strange for Mohamed. Niazi was the one who had helped him report Craig. Why were the FBI agents asking about him? By the spring of 2007, the FBI had honed in on Niazi. It's unclear exactly why, but court records reveal one thing that got their attention. One of Niazi's sisters was married to a man named Amin al-Haq. Al-Haq was designated as a terrorist by the US government. He'd allegedly served as a security coordinator for Osama bin Laden.
这对穆罕默德来说很奇怪。尼亚兹是那个帮他举报克雷格的人。为什么FBI特工要问他？到2007年春天，FBI已经锁定尼亚兹。不清楚确切原因，但法庭记录揭示了一件事引起了他们的注意。尼亚兹的一个姐妹嫁给了一个叫阿明·哈克（Amin al-Haq）的人。哈克被美国政府指定为恐怖分子。据称他曾担任本·拉登的安全协调员。
And Niazi also said things to Craig that concerned the FBI. None of Craig's recordings have been released, so we don't know what exactly they talked about, but Craig gave us dozens of emails Niazi sent him. They're mostly articles and links to videos.
而且尼亚兹也对克雷格说了让FBI担心的话。克雷格的录音没有一份被发布，所以我们不知道他们到底谈论了什么，但克雷格给了我们尼亚兹发给他的几十封电子邮件。它们大多是文章和视频链接。
Some of these are about conspiracy theories, like how 9/11 was an inside job. Others criticized the wars in Afghanistan and Iraq, sometimes calling for Muslims to rise up against their enemies. This YouTube video is the most extreme thing my producer and I found in the emails. It's an email I'm talking about how he supports Osama bin Laden.
其中一些是关于阴谋论的，比如“9·11”是一次监守自盗。其他的批评阿富汗和伊拉克的战争，有时呼吁穆斯林奋起反抗他们的敌人。这个YouTube视频是我和我的制作人发现的邮件中最极端的东西。我在谈论关于他支持本·拉登的一封邮件。
If he is terrorizing the terrorist, if he is terrorizing America the terrorist-- biggest terrorist-- I am with him. Every Muslim should be a terrorist. The thing is that, if he's terrorizing a terrorist, he's for Islam!
如果他在恐吓恐怖分子，如果他在恐吓恐怖分子美国——最大的恐怖分子——我与他同在。每个穆斯林都应该是恐怖分子。关键是，如果他在恐吓一个恐怖分子，他就是为了伊斯兰教！
In case you didn't get that, he said every Muslim should be a terrorist. Niazi sent this video to an undercover FBI informant, Craig.
如果你没听明白，他说每个穆斯林都应该是恐怖分子。尼亚兹把这个视频发给了FBI卧底线人克雷格。
They said that I hit a jackpot with Niazi. They call it a jackpot.
他们说我抓到了尼亚兹这个大奖。他们称之为“大奖”。
Even after Niazi turned Craig in, for nearly a year, the FBI continued to surveil Niazi. Finally, two agents came to talk to him. After they left, Niazi immediately called Hussam Ayloush at CAIR.
甚至在尼亚兹举报克雷格后，FBI又监视了尼亚兹近一年。最后，两名特工来找他谈话。他们离开后，尼亚兹立即打给了CAIR的胡萨姆·艾卢什。
He actually was crying. I mean, he was crying like a little kid, very fearful. And he kept repeating, I'm the one who called the FBI. I'm the one, and now they're turning on me?
他当时在哭。我的意思是，他像个小孩子一样哭，非常恐惧。他不断重复，是我打电话给FBI的。是我，现在他们转而对付我了？
The lead agent who met with Niazi was Thomas Ropel, who handled his case inside the FBI. Niazi said Ropel threatened him, told him that the FBI had something on him, told Niazi that he'd lied to them-- which is a federal crime-- at an earlier meeting with FBI agents, one of the meetings where Niazi thought he was there to help the FBI catch Craig. Here's Hussam.
与尼亚兹见面的带队特工是托马斯·罗佩尔（Thomas Ropel），他在FBI内部处理他的案子。尼亚兹说罗佩尔威胁他，告诉他FBI掌握了他的把柄，告诉尼亚兹他在之前的会谈中对他们撒了谎——这在联邦法律中是犯罪——在那之前的会谈中，尼亚兹以为他是去帮忙FBI抓捕克雷格的。这是胡萨姆。
And the agent actually told him, based on our interviews with you, you've made comments that are not accurate, and this would be perjury. And I feel bad for you, but you know, it's in your hands. You can change all of that if you cooperate with us. They said, you know, you speak Arabic, Pashto, and Dari, and you could be a great asset in helping us protect the country.
特工实际上告诉他，根据我们对你的采访，你所发表的评论是不准确的，这是伪证。我为你感到遗憾，但你知道，这取决于你自己。如果你配合我们，你可以改变这一切。他们说，你知道，你会说阿拉伯语、普什图语和达里语，你可以成为帮助我们保护国家的巨大资产。
He said, well, that's what I did. I don't need to work for you. When I saw something bad, I'm the one who picked up the phone and reported it. So, well, we need you here, and we need you in Afghanistan. They offered them to be in Afghanistan, and they offered him money.
他说，好吧，那就是我做的。我不需要为你工作。当我看到不好的事情时，是我打电话举报它的。所以，好吧，我们需要你在那里，我们需要你在阿富汗。他们提议让他去阿富汗，并提出给他钱。
He said, I'm not going to go and spy on my people. I told you, if I see something bad, I'll report it. And then the guy told him, I hope you think about it, because if you don't, we can make your life a living hell.
他说，我不去监视我的人民。我告诉你，如果我看到不好的事情，我会举报。然后那个家伙告诉他，我希望你好好考虑一下，因为如果你不这样做，我们可以让你的生活变成人间地狱。
That's what they said to him?
他们对他说了那个？
That's exactly the quote he gave me, because I wrote it down as he was talking to me.
那是他给我的准确引用，因为当他对我说话时我把它记了下来。
Thomas Ropel confirmed in court that this meeting happened, though he did not say that he pressured Niazi to work for the FBI. But ex-FBI agents my producer and I talked to said it's common to leverage people like this. Again, they weren't commenting on Niazi's case, but one retired agent who had more than 20 years' experience in the Bureau said there are people all over the country being approached by the FBI and pressured with things they said on tapes.
托马斯·罗佩尔在法庭上证实了这次会议确实发生过，尽管他没有说他曾向尼亚兹施压让他为FBI工作。但我制作人和我交谈过的前FBI探员说，利用人做这种事很常见。他们再次没有对尼亚兹的案子发表评论，但一位拥有超过20年FBI经验的退休探员说，全国各地都有人被FBI接触并用他们在录音带上说的话施压。
He laughed when we asked him about it. It was like asking a plumber if he used a wrench. He says it happens at every level of law enforcement. He told us, quote, "It sounds like a terrible thing, guys, but it's the way business is done. It's the way the American people get protected. You've got to find people who can lead you to the bad guys."
当我们问起这件事时，他笑了。这就像问水管工是否使用了扳手一样。他说这发生在执法的每一个层面。他告诉我们，引用，“伙计们，这听起来是一件可怕的事情，但这就是做生意的方式。这就是美国人民得到保护的方式。你必须找到能引导你找到坏人的人。”
Thomas Ropel returned with a group of agents and a search warrant. They raided Niazi's house, taking computers and financial documents. Months later, Ropel returned again and arrested Niazi.
托马斯·罗佩尔带着一群特工和搜查令回来了。他们突袭了尼亚兹的房子，拿走了电脑和财务文件。几个月后，罗佩尔再次回来并逮捕了尼亚兹。
For the second time, federal authorities move in on this Tustin home. Their target? The 34-year-old owner.
联邦当局第二次突袭了这个塔斯廷（Tustin）的家。他们的目标？34岁的房主。
Tonight, this local home looks empty, but today, it was the scene of an FBI raid. The suspect? A man with alleged ties to terrorists.
今晚，这个当地的家看起来空荡荡的，但今天，它是FBI突袭的现场。嫌疑人？一个与恐怖分子有嫌疑联系的男人。
The government charged Niazi with immigration fraud and making false statements. They said that when Niazi applied for US citizenship, he didn't mention that his sister was married to Amin al-Haq even though you're required to disclose if you have any ties to a designated terrorist. They also charged him for using inconsistent versions of his full name on official forums and for not disclosing two trips he'd made to Pakistan years earlier.
政府指控尼亚兹移民欺诈和作假陈述。他们说，尼亚兹在申请美国公民身份时，没有提到他的姐妹嫁给了阿明·哈克，尽管你被要求披露是否与指定恐怖分子有任何联系。他们还指控他在官方表格上使用不一致的全名，并且没有披露他多年前去过巴基斯坦的两次行程。
But what's interesting about Niazi's arrest is what he wasn't charged with. He wasn't charged with associating with terrorists himself, he wasn't charged with plotting an attack, and he wasn't charged for anything he'd ever said to Craig over the course of months of recorded conversations. Still, at Niazi's bail hearing, the prosecutor argued that he was a danger to the community. To prove that, she called Agent Thomas Ropel to the stand.
但尼亚兹被捕引人注目的地方在于他没有被指控什么。他没有被指控自己与恐怖分子交往，没有被指控策划袭击，也没有被指控在数月录音对话中对克雷格说过任何话。尽管如此，在尼亚兹的保释听证会上，检察官争辩说他是社区的危险人物。为了证明这一点，她传唤了特工托马斯·罗佩尔上庭。
Will you please state your full name for the record?
请为记录陈述你的全名好吗？
Special Agent Thomas J. Ropel III.
特别探员托马斯·J·罗佩尔三世。
How do you spell your last name, please?
请问你的姓氏怎么拼？
R-O-P-E-L.
R-O-P-E-L。
Thank you.
谢谢。
Ropel testified that a confidential informant had recorded the Niazi talking about jihad between 15 and 20 times. In addition, he said--
罗佩尔作证说，一名线人记录了尼亚兹谈论“圣战”15到20次。此外，他说——
There were some recordings that I had personally listened to regarding Mr. Niazi discussing gaining access to weapons and discussing blowing up buildings. And--
有一些录音我个人听过，关于尼亚兹先生讨论获得武器和讨论炸毁建筑物。而且——
As Ropel went on, the judge asked him to clarify who had brought up these conversations-- Niazi, or the informant?
当罗佩尔继续说时，法官要求他澄清是谁提出了这些谈话——尼亚兹，还是线人？
--Mr. Niazi has instigated these conversations with an individual.
——尼亚兹先生向个人挑起了这些谈话。
He instigated the conversations?
他挑起了谈话？
Mr. Niazi did. Yes, correct.
尼亚兹先生做到了。是的，正确。
Of course, the individual he supposedly instigated the conversations with was Craig Monteilh. I asked Craig about it.
当然，他理应挑起谈话的那个人是克雷格·蒙泰伊。我问了克雷格。
Did Niazi ever instigate this kind of conversation with you?
尼亚兹有没有对你挑起这种谈话？
No, no. I did, every time.
没有，没有。每一次都是我挑起的。
Craig has changed his story on this. When Niazi was arrested in 2009, he basically said the complete opposite. He said Niazi recruited him for a terrorist operation. But Craig says now he's telling the truth. He says what really happened is that he went after Niazi more aggressively than anyone. Niazi wanted a friend, and he tolerated Craig's jihad talk more than most.
克雷格在这点上改变了他的说法。当尼亚兹2009年被捕时，他基本上说了完全相反的话。他说尼亚兹招募他进行恐怖行动。但克雷格现在说他在讲真话。他说真正发生的是他比任何人都更具攻击性地针对尼亚兹。尼亚兹想要一个朋友，他对克雷格的“圣战”言论比大多数人更能忍受。在被录音时做那种事是非常糟糕的。
The thing about Niazi was he tried to impress me. He's like 5'5" or so, and I was somewhat intimidating to him, so he just went along with what I said. He didn't say he wanted to be a part of this, but he didn't say to me, no, I don't. It's a very bad thing to do when you're being recorded.
有没有那种感觉，我抓住了这个在意识形态上倾向于“圣战”的家伙？
Did you feel like, I've got this guy who's ideologically leaning towards jihad?
我当时想的是，我可以把他带到那里。他很害怕。他看起来很害怕，这也是我想要他处在的状态。我的上线告诉我要把他拉得更近。他简直被我迷住了。
What I thought was, I can bring him there. He was afraid. He looked like he was scared, which is where I wanted him to be. And my handlers told me to reel him in more. And he was just mesmerized by me.
我交谈过认识尼亚兹的人，他们支持这一点。尼亚兹指导了克雷格，但与此同时，他被他吸引了——至少直到他和穆罕默德决定把克雷格举报给FBI的那一刻。政府将尼亚兹软禁了一年多，有宵禁和电子脚镣。当我为了这个故事联系尼亚兹时，他发给我一份声明。其中部分写道：“当FBI特工威胁说除非我成为线人——我拒绝了——否则会让我的生活变成人间地狱时，FBI兑现了它的承诺，确实让我的生活变成了人间地狱。过去几年，我和我的家人一直在非常努力地试图拼凑回我们的生活。”
I talked to people who know Niazi, and they backed this up. Niazi mentored Craig, but at the same time, he was enthralled by him-- at least until the moment when he and Mohamed decided to turn Craig in to the FBI. The government kept Niazi under house arrest for more than a year, with a curfew and an ankle bracelet. When I reached out to Niazi for this story, he sent me a statement. It says in part, "When the FBI agent threatened to make my life a living hell unless I became an informant-- which I refused-- the FBI made true its promise and really did make my life a living hell. In the past few years, my family and I have been struggling very hard to piece back together our lives."
政府最终决定不想追究尼亚兹的案子。它提交了一份驳回所有指控的动议。“Flex行动”在没有任何已知定罪的情况下结束。
The government eventually decided it didn't want to pursue Niazi's case. It filed a motion to dismiss all of the charges. Operation Flex ended without a single known conviction.
不过有一个人进了监狱——克雷格·蒙泰伊。在克雷格被举报为潜在恐怖分子六个月后，尔湾警察以一个奇怪的无关罪名逮捕了他。事实证明，在“Flex行动”期间，他一直在做副业，在一个贩运人类生长激素的计划中骗取了两名女性超过15万美元。他在监视穆斯林的同一个健身房遇见了她们。
One person did go to jail, though-- Craig Monteilh. Six months after Craig was reported as a potential terrorist, the Irvine Police arrested him for a bizarre, unrelated crime. It turned out that during Operation Flex, he'd been running a side hustle, conning two women out of more than $150,000 in a scheme to traffic human growth hormone. He met the women at the same gyms where he was monitoring Muslims.
他入狱了八个月。克雷格为此起诉了FBI，声称整件事是FBI缉毒行动的一部分，并且在他失去用处后，他的上线串通让他被捕。一位法官最近驳回了这个案子。
He went to prison for eight months. Craig sued the FBI over this, claiming the whole thing was part of an FBI drug sting and that his handlers conspired to have him arrested after he became useless in Operation Flex. A judge recently threw the case out.
你大概能想象“Flex行动”及其后续对奥兰治县FBI与穆斯林社区之间的关系做了什么。CAIR南加州负责人胡萨姆·艾卢什记得在尼亚兹保释听证会上，FBI透露克雷格是卧底线人那一刻。胡萨姆当时就在法庭里。
You can probably imagine what Operation Flex and its aftermath did to relations between the FBI and the Muslim community in Orange County. Hussam Ayloush, the head of CAIR in Southern California, remembers the moment at Niazi's bail hearing when the FBI revealed that Craig was an undercover informant. Hussam was in the courtroom.
那几乎就像一把匕首刺进我的背部。我感到被背叛——整个社区，不仅仅是我。我们感到被背叛，因为我们谈论的是伙伴关系。如果你看到什么，举报它。如果你怀疑犯罪行为，打电话给警察。人们当时说，为什么我们要那样做？我们要成为调查的目标。
It was almost like a dagger in my back. I felt betrayed-- the whole community, not just me. We felt betrayed, because we talk about a partnership. If you see something, report it. If you suspect criminal behavior, call the police. People were saying, why should we do it? We're going to be the one, the target of the investigation.
现实是，他们从没把我们当作伙伴。对他们来说，我们都是嫌疑人。我们一直被视为嫌疑人或潜在恐怖分子。
The reality is, they never thought of us as partners. For them, we were all suspects. We were always deemed as suspects or potential terrorists.
“Flex行动”不仅让人们怀疑执法部门，还让人们互相猜忌。我交谈过的许多人说他们现在远离新皈依者。他们很难相信人们是他们所说的那样。这是艾曼，那个最初与克雷格交朋友的埃及人。
Operation Flex didn't just make people suspicious of law enforcement, it made them suspicious of each other. So many people I talked to said they stay away from new converts now. They have a hard time believing people are who they say they are. Here's Ayman, the Egyptian guy who first befriended Craig.
真的，他们所做的是让清真寺里的每个人都不信任每个人。没有人会谈论它，但没有人会……你会看到一些奇怪的眼神，你知道我的意思吗？人们看着彼此的方式很奇怪。我不知道。也许我太敏感了，但我能看出他们看我的方式是不一样的。
Really, what they did is they made everybody in the mosque not trust everybody. Nobody, nobody would talk about it, but nobody would-- you would see some weird looks, you know what I mean? People are looking at each other weird. I don't know. Maybe I was sensitive, but I can tell that the way they looked at me was just different.
在这个故事最尴尬的发展之一中，穆斯林社区现在与克雷格·蒙泰伊合作。CAIR连同美国公民自由联盟（ACLU）正在起诉FBI的“Flex行动”。政府在回应中辩称，允许此案继续进行将揭示国家机密并危害国家安全。克雷格是CAIR在此案中的主要资源。他现在正在帮助那些他曾经监视的人。
In one of the most awkward developments of this story, the Muslim community is now teaming up with Craig Monteilh. The Council on American-Islamic Relations, CAIR, along with the ACLU, is suing the FBI Operation Flex. The government is arguing in response that allowing the case to go forward would reveal state secrets and harm national security. Craig is CAIR's primary resource in the case. He's now helping the people he used to spy on.
而且他也向他们中的一些人道歉了。他经常见到他们，因为他仍然住在尔湾清真寺附近，并在同一个健身房健身。他特别强调要给亚瑟·阿卜杜勒拉希姆打电话，他是他最初接触的人之一。
And he's been apologizing to some of them, too. He sees them often, because he still lives around the corner from the Irvine mosque and works out in the same gym. He made a special point of calling Yasser AbdelRahim, one of the first people he got close to.
我确实感谢他打电话来，并为此道歉，但伤害已经造成了。我不知道该做什么，我真的不知道。我现在有一种我一直在被监视的恐惧。我不知道你该怎么改变那种感觉。
I definitely appreciate the fact that he called, and that he apologized for it, but the damage is done. I don't know what to do, I really don't. I now have a fear that I'm being monitored all the time. I don't know how you can change that.
克雷格并不是唯一一个道歉的人。在尼亚兹的指控被驳回后，他来到法院取回FBI从他家里扣押的一些财产。托马斯·罗佩尔在那里。他们谈了大约20分钟。记住，罗佩尔是那个据称威胁尼亚兹的探员，后来逮捕了他，然后又在法庭上作证说他是社会的危险人物。
Craig's not the only one apologizing. After Niazi's charges were dismissed, he went to the courthouse to retrieve some of the property that the FBI had seized from his house. Thomas Ropel was there. They talked for about 20 minutes. Remember, Ropel is the agent who allegedly threatened Niazi, who later arrested him, and who then testified in court that he was a danger to society.
我和陪同尼亚兹参加这次会议的法院雇员交谈过。在他们离开前，罗佩尔走到尼亚兹身边并和他握手。他告诉尼亚兹错误已经发生了。我们都是人类，他说。我很抱歉。
I spoke to the court employee who accompanied Niazi to this meeting. Before they left, Ropel went over to Niazi and shook his hand. He told Niazi that mistakes had been made. We're all human, he said. I'm sorry.
萨姆·布莱克。他是一位纪录片制作人。他关于被谋杀的沙特记者贾迈勒·卡舒吉（Jamal Khashoggi）的最新电影《沉默王国》（Kingdom of Silence）正在Showtime上线。
Sam Black. He's a documentary filmmaker. His latest film, Kingdom of Silence, about murdered Saudi journalist Jamal Khashoggi, is streaming on Showtime.
就像我们之前所说的，从这些事件中产生的最高法院案件上个月进行了辩论。案件的核心问题，《联邦调查局诉法扎加案》，是FBI是否仅仅因为他们是穆斯林而在监视人们——如果属实，那将违宪。但最高法院没有听取关于那个问题的辩论。经历了这么久，法院系统还没有涉及到那个问题，因为政府试图让此案被驳回。
Like we said earlier, the Supreme Court case that came out of these events was argued last month. The central issue in the case, FBI versus Fazaga, is whether the FBI was spying on people just because they were Muslim-- which, if true, would be unconstitutional. But the Supreme Court wasn't hearing arguments on that question. After all this time, the court system hasn't gotten to that question, because the government is trying to get the case thrown out.
政府说FBI监视所有这些人有很好的理由，但为了建立适当的辩护并解释这些理由是什么，他们将不得不揭示会损害国家安全的秘密信息——国家机密。他们说因为涉及国家机密，法院应该完全驳回此案。代表尔湾穆斯林社区提出诉讼的律师在美国最高法院辩论说这做得太过分了。他们不必驳回此案。还有案件可以继续推进的方式。
The government says the FBI had good reasons to surveil all these people, but to mount a proper defense and explain what those reasons are, they would have to reveal secret information-- state secrets-- that would compromise national security. And they're saying that because there are state secrets involved, the court should throw out the case entirely. The lawyers bringing the suit on behalf of the Muslim community in Irvine argued before the Supreme Court that this goes too far. They don't have to throw out the case. There are ways the case can still move forward.
其中一种，有一项法律——《外国情报监视法》（FISA）——将允许法官查看机密材料。国家机密仍然不会公开。法官可以看到它们；没人能看到。然后，法官将对案件做出决定。或者，律师们说，法院可以不带任何秘密证据让案件继续——只是把那些东西排除在案件之外。
One of them, there's a law-- the Foreign Intelligence Surveillance Act, or FISA-- that would allow a judge to look at the classified materials. The state secrets still would not be public. The judge could see them; nobody else could. And then, the judge would come to a decision in the case. Or, the lawyers say, the courts could just let the case proceed without any secret evidence at all-- just leave that stuff out of the case.
在他们看来，这里更大的原则是，应该有一种方法让人们在法庭上有发言权，即使在政府声称存在国家机密的案件中也是如此。如果最高法院确实允许案件继续进行，代表穆斯林社区辩论此案的律师阿希兰·阿鲁拉南瑟姆（Ahilan Arulanantham）说，最终，如果他们赢了，他们希望销毁监视行动中收集的所有信息。
The bigger principle here, in their view, is that there should be a way for people to get their day in court, even in a case where the government claims there are state secrets. If the Supreme Court does allow the case to go forward, the lawyer who argued the case for the Muslim community, Ahilan Arulanantham, said ultimately, if they win, they want all the information gathered in the surveillance operation to be destroyed.
这对这个社区的人来说非常重要。他们真的很不满，政府在他们仅仅过着自己的生活，早上去清真寺，到处晃悠时监视他们。就像你听到亚瑟·阿卜杜勒拉希姆和他的室友玩Xbox，《FIFA》一样。政府监视并获取所有那些信息对人们来说是非常深深冒犯的。它坐在FBI的某个数字金库里的某个地方，他们想烧掉所有那些东西。
And that is really important to the people in this community. They really were upset that the government spied on them while they were just living their lives, going to mosque in the morning, hanging out. Like you heard Yasser AbdelRahim playing Xbox, FIFA, with his roommates. And it's really deeply offensive to people that the government spied, got all that information. It's sitting somewhere in some digital vault in the FBI, and they want all of that burned.
[音乐 - 詹姆斯·墨菲（James Murphy）的《请别跟着我》]
[MUSIC - "PLEASE DON'T FOLLOW ME" BY JAMES MURPHY]
好的，我们今天的节目由丽莎·波洛克（Lisa Pollock）与亚历克斯·布隆伯格（Alex Blumberg）、本·卡尔霍恩（Ben Calhoun）、莎拉·柯尼格（Sarah Koenig）、乔纳森·门吉瓦尔（Jonathan Menjivar）、布莱恩·里德（Brian Reed）、罗宾·塞米恩（Robyn Semien）、阿丽莎·希普（Alissa Shipp）和南希·厄普代克（Nancy Updike）制作。本集的资深制作人是朱莉·斯奈德（Julie Snyder）。音乐帮助来自达米安·格拉夫（Damien Graef）和罗伯·格德斯（Rob Geddes）。今天重播的制作帮助来自凯瑟琳·雷·蒙多（Katherine Rae Mondo）、斯托·尼尔森（Stowe Nelson）、马特·蒂尔尼（Matt Tierney）和克洛伊·韦纳（Chloe Weiner）。特别感谢佩特拉·巴托谢维奇（Petra Bartosiewicz）、迪娜·坦普尔-拉斯顿（Dina Temple-Raston）、萨拉·戈德布拉特（Sara Goldblatt）、赛勒斯·麦戈德里克（Cyrus McGoldrick）、本杰明·阿纳斯塔斯（Benjamin Anastas）、阿米娜·卡齐（Ameena Qazi）、阿法德·谢赫（Affad Shaikh）和劳伦斯·赖特（Lawrence Wright）。今天还要感谢迈克尔·德国（Michael German）、马西·法鲁迪（Masih Faloudi）、穆罕默德·塔伊萨尔（Mohammad Tajsar）、胡萨姆·艾卢什和特雷弗·阿伦森，萨姆采访的那位关于500起FBI案件的记者。他有一本关于那些案件的书，《恐怖工厂：走进FBI捏造的恐怖战争》。
Well, our program was produced today by Lisa Pollock with Alex Blumberg, Ben Calhoun, Sarah Koenig, Jonathan Menjivar, Brian Reed, Robyn Semien, Alissa Shipp, and Nancy Updike. Our senior producer for this episode was Julie Snyder. Music help from Damien Graef and from Rob Geddes. Production help on today's rerun from Katherine Rae Mondo, Stowe Nelson, Matt Tierney, and Chloe Weiner. Special thanks today to Petra Bartosiewicz Dina Temple-Raston, Sara Goldblatt, Cyrus McGoldrick, Benjamin Anastas, Ameena Qazi, Affad Shaikh, and Lawrence Wright. Thanks also today to Michael German, Masih Faloudi, Mohammad Tajsar, Hussam Ayloush, and Trevor Aaronson, the journalist Sam interviewed about the 500 FBI cases. He has a book about those cases, The Terror Factory: Inside the FBI's Manufactured War on Terrorism.
我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org，在那里你可以免费流媒体播放我们超过750集节目的档案。还有视频。有最喜爱节目的列表。上面还有很多其他东西。再次说明，thisamericanlife.org。
Our website, thisamericanlife.org, where you can stream our archive of over 750 episodes for absolutely free. Also, there's videos. There's lists of favorite shows. There's tons of other stuff there, too. Again thisamericanlife.org.
《美国生活》由公共广播交换中心（PRX）分发给公共广播电台。像往常一样感谢我们的老板，托里·马拉蒂亚（Torey Malatia）先生——你可能知道这一点——他每天早上起得很早，掀开被子，看看闹钟，深吸一口气，告诉世界——
This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks, as always, to our boss, Mr. Torey Malatia who-- and you may know this-- he wakes up early every morning, throws off the covers, looks at the alarm clock, takes a deep breath, and tells the world--
5:45 AM，我进入状态了。
5:45 AM, and I am hot.
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life.
下周在《美国生活》播客上，故事是关于当你遵循规则、行事负责、照顾他人福利、当你成为情况中的成年人，而事情没有为你解决时会发生什么。你没有得到回报。那些无视规则的人跳到你前面。简而言之，我们正在谈论当你做对了一切却导致一事无成时发生的最令人沮丧的事情之一。下周在播客或你当地的公共广播电台收听真实故事。
Next week on the podcast of This American Life, stories of what happens when you follow the rules, act responsibly, look out for others' welfare, when you're the grown-up in the situation, and things do not work out for you. You do not get rewarded. Others who ignore the rules jump ahead of you. In short, we're talking about one of the most frustrating things that happens when you do everything right, and it leads nowhere. True tales next week on the podcast or on your local public radio station.
下周的《美国生活》播客将讲述当人们遵循规则、行事负责、顾全大局、在局面中表现成熟，结果却事与愿违时的故事。你没有得到应有的回报，而那些无视规则的人却抢在了你前面。简而言之，我们要探讨的是那种最令人沮丧的情况：当你一切都做得对，却换不来任何结果。下周请收听播客或当地公共广播电台，了解这些真实的故事。